podemos pensar que el sistema nervioso
central está dividido en dos partes la
rama del sistema nervioso autónomo y
como el nombre lo indica este es el
control automático la parte involuntaria
que mencionamos anteriormente además de
esto tenemos la rama de lo que
controlamos a voluntad que se llama
sistema nervioso somático es algo que
podemos controlar en el sistema autónomo
tenemos dos partes una es el sistema
nervioso simpático lo hemos mencionado
cuando hablamos del ganglio simpático
que es parte del control involuntario
además hay un sistema nervioso
parasimpático que está en una situación
de equilibrio con el sistema nervioso
simpático el sistema nervioso somático
tiene una función controlar el músculo
voluntario el neurotransmisor que se usa
aquí y que escribo entre paréntesis es
la acetilcolina y la abreviados como ch
y que hay de los neurotransmisores que
son usados por los sistemas nervioso
simpático y parasimpático pues ya los
conocemos al menos
del sistema nervioso simpático y los
podemos recordar preguntándonos qué es
lo que hace el sistema nervioso
simpático seguramente han escuchado
acerca de la respuesta de pelear o huir
esto ocurre cuando nos encontramos en
una situación peligrosa en la que el
cuerpo dice o no me puedo morir en
cualquier momento lo que activa el
sistema nervioso simpático para poder
pelear o huir la adrenalina comienza a
fluir por el cuerpo el corazón comienza
a latir más fuerte y más rápido para
poder enviar más oxígeno a las piernas y
así poder correr más rápido y escapar
esto es pelear o huir mencioné la
adrenalina que es una hormona endocrina
que es secretada para ayudar con esto
pero tiene una amiga neurotransmisora
que hace lo mismo y esta amiga que voy a
escribir no es la adrenalina sino
noradrenalina también llamada
norepinefrina vamos a escribirlo
norepinefrina o noradrenalina este es el
neurotransmisor del sistema nervioso
simpático
y del sistema nervioso parasimpático
pues curiosamente usa el mismo
neurotransmisor que el sistema nervioso
somático y la forma en la que podemos
diferenciarlo del sistema nervioso
simpático es que mientras que el sistema
nervioso simpático se activa en estos
momentos super intensos para pelear o
huir
el propósito del sistema parasimpático
es más relajado ya que es para descansar
y digerir como cuando van a dormir y se
tratan de relajar para que disminuya el
ritmo cardíaco de manera que los
músculos y el corazón no se contraigan
tan rápidamente o si han comido una gran
cena y necesitan digerir ese alimento el
sistema nervioso parasimpático le dirá
al estómago que deshaga ese alimento
para poder digerirlo en el intestino a
donde lo expulsa con el movimiento de
los músculos suaves eso es logrado por
la acetilcolina muy bien estas son las
dos divisiones principales del sistema
nervioso central autónomo y somático